most women they start taking the pill  they get massively depressed mentally  ill to be completely honest that hasn't  been advantageous for women either and  that is a side effect that hits most  people but most people started so young  that they don't know that it's happening  to them people should be aware of that  information before going on the pill  they should be aware of the fact that  their sexual preferences change while  they're on the pill i don't think the  fault is necessarily with women and we  need to come up with way forward with  all the information so that people are  aware if you wait until you're 30 you're  gonna have a harder time having kids and  that's not society's fault that's just  biology when you give people access to  the information it shouldn't end up with  anybody being angry about it the way  society is right now is really making  everybody suffer